et je me tourne vers voire même charrier
bonjour armelle pour aller plus loin
dans quelques heures donc il y aura sept
cette rencontre américaine re se sont
déjà parlé on a en tête évidemment les
chefs de diplomatie qui se sont
retrouvés récemment à stockholm c'est la
première fois en revanche que les chefs
d'état vont se se parler franchement
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de ce
rendez vous on a l'air de dire pas grand
chose vous avez certainement tort pas
grand chose simplement ils se parlent
l'enjeu est en fait de dire s'ils
s'entendent assez bien sûr ce sommet
virtuel on pourra imaginer qu'ils en
aient en présentiel au printemps et si à
une rencontre directe dans ces cas là ce
sera peut-être dans ce plus porteurs là
vous avez raison de rappeler le canada
et y la bête c'est que quand les chefs
de la diplomatie se sont rencontrés
c'est bien qu'ils aient préparer ce
sommet virtuel et qu'en fait les
américains essaient de jouer toutes les
cartes pour avertir justement de cette
escalade il ya même le directeur de la
cia qui est parti en europe du côté de
l'ukraine donc on a vraiment cette
inquiétude là du côté des américains qui
disent trop de troupes massées trop de
volonté de la part de poutine
certainement de faire un dérapage dans
la région du dombass du côté de
l'ukraine et cette inquiétude qui en
ressort ce sommet virtuel ça sert aussi
quand même à ça à passer dans la
désescalade mais est ce que justement
joe biden va jouer sur les sanctions
sont sur l'économie qu'il a déjà imposé
est-ce qu'il va aller un petit peu plus
loin avec tout le système swift derrière
qui fait un arrêt d'exclusion de la
russie sur ce système interbancaire les
dérangerait davantage parce que
évidemment du côté des russes on alarme
toujours du gaz qui acheminent qui est
acheminé en europe parce que vous êtes
en train de dire c'est qu'en coulisse on
est effectivement assez inquiet de
l'attitude des uns et des autres
ce niveau de tension ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas assisté à
cela malheureusement oui parce qu'on a
bien dû tension au travers de la planète
et on n'avait pas besoin d'avoir sa au
coeur de l'europe on voit bien
effectivement que le président ukrainien
et links qui est très inquiet lui aussi
et donc du coup sont façon de répondre
c'est qu'ils arment ils achètent
américain il achète des armes des
américains il a acheté des armes en eaux
turques des drones ça ça énerve et
vladimir poutine et donc à tout moment
il peut y avoir le pas de trop qui est
fait d'un côté ou de l'autre peut-être
pas du côté des russes qui savent qu
entend très bien quand est-ce qu'il faut
manoeuvrer ou qu est ce qu il faut
s'arrêter et cetera mais si par hasard
on a une explosion du côté ukrainien là
on aura de toute manière les russes qui
rentreront bille en tête sur ce qui est
en train de se passer et derrière on
sait pas comment vont réagir ni les
européens ni les américains donc
aujourd'hui tous les systèmes de
renseignement sont très observateur de
ce qui se passe dans la zone en se
rappelant effectivement qu'il faut
négocier avec discernement vis-à-vis des
russes qui connaissent parfaitement les
stratégies pour faire avancer
l'adversaire vers la wii veulent mais en
sachant aussi voir les discernement vis
à vis des américains qui ont parfois
subi gonfler les événements quand il le
fallait en a forcément en tête l'irak
par exemple merci beaucoup armelle pour
le décryptage évidemment on suivra ce
que donne cet entretien par
visioconférence en fin d'après midi
l'initiative